foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so hello hello everybody hope you are
having a fabulous fabulous day welcome
to
daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and as the hostess of this program I am
excited to say hello to you and welcome
welcome to an hour of empowering
information that gives you Tools in your
toolbox to be able to
look at yourself and say okay I've got
this this and this going on
why doctors can't figure it out well
guess what we do have a doctor that has
figured it out and in this hour Dr Joel
Wallach who has
done so so much at looking at cause and
effect
when something's going on what is it
what is it causing elsewhere what's
caught going on Downstream
well through his research
in
agriculture
as a doctor of veterinary medicine
three post doctorates and pathology I
don't know anybody else that has
post-doctorates in pathology and have
written
a National Treasure that's held in the
Smithsonian Institute which was his
thesis called exotic diseases of exotic
animals
and then taught nutrition
after getting fired for finding
the cause and here and prevention of
what was said to be genetic diseases and
then it was has been deemed as one of
the founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics that proves the genetic
theory of disease transmission to be
incorrect
he's debunked it folks so if you've been
told that you have a genetic condition
there's a good chance that it's not
genetic
and
after being fired for making that
finding
and then getting somebody else fired
because they found that cure for
something else
like muscular dystrophy
he or that actually I'm getting the the
chronological order in messed up a
little bit
because he started teaching after being
fired at a naturopathic College teaching
nutrition
and then figured that since she was
already at the naturopathic college and
he had you know really nothing better to
do because he wasn't traveling he was
teaching that he would just stick around
a little bit longer and get a degree and
become a naturopathic physician
and from that he started putting his
findings into formulations and putting
him into work in his clinics and wanted
to go big folks so we are going big here
out in the digital world and spreading
his message Monday through most Fridays
here on daily with Doc Zoom so if you
are watching on rumble on Facebook on
YouTube we welcome you as well you are
part of our live audience whether you're
watching the replay or watching us at
the moment
that is awesome
share this with somebody else that's how
we are going to be able to go really big
by people taking this information and
empowering themselves to empower others
to take a look at alternative
they're not alternative though it's
natural ways of addressing and giving
the body what it needs so that it can
Thrive so Dr Joel Wallach I just want to
say thank you for being here with us
once again on daily with Doc I know that
you've got some great information to
share with us today and we're talking
about the kidneys
so what else do you have to add about
the kidneys today Dr Wallach
well
um I put the kitties in the same package
as the brain the heart the lungs the
liver and the kidneys okay soft tissue
soft tissue but it has it has function
okay and
um the kidneys if you have things going
on like coronary arteries people say oh
yeah I bet coronary arteries of the
plaque in my arteries and my hearts and
the doctor says it's affecting my brain
can't get enough oxygen to the brain
well if you have plaque in your arteries
in your heart
guess what you get plaque then the
arteries in your kidneys
now your kidneys
have many many many functions much like
the liver has an enormous amount of
functions
okay
include including filtering the blood
including producing urine
including dealing with blood pressure
okay
and
um it which I say it does a lot of
screening
and people really have really no earthly
idea how much the kidney does so that's
why you can go to a pharmacy without a
prescription you can get urine test
strips and you know either pee on the
test strip or pee in a cup and then you
put the test strip in the Pea in the cup
and it'll tell you what's going on in
your urine oh my gosh you have lots of
sugar in my urine I got diabetes Well
probably okay and of course you need to
check your blood coming from your arm or
a stick in the finger or something like
that and see what your blood sugar is
there
okay and then if you do have diabetes
you got the warning from the kidney okay
and usually you're going to have that's
what's called polyuria I don't know why
but I'm urinating
two three times an hour I just I can't
even sit down because I urinate and then
I turn around and go sit down I have to
urinate it again I go to sit down I'd
have to urinate again well that's
because the kidney is responding to
build up of fluids in the body trying to
get rid of all that excess edema and
fluids
and also
um the the
um glomeruli okay which are the little
filtering units in the kidneys
um they produce hormones to tell your
blood vessels what to do and muscles
what to do and so forth and help you
with blood sugar issues and and so on
and then also blood pressure
but we have elevated blood pressure
there the doctors run immediately to the
heart well that's not a bad thing to run
and look at the heart
but you can have clogged arteries in the
kidneys and that's going to cause you to
have serious high blood pressure issues
okay
and so the kidneys are not a simple
two you know you just pee three times a
day because you have kidneys
um it's working
while you're asleep it's working day and
night and so you really have to pay
attention to what's going on because
your kidneys will give you the clue
um when you have polyurea and you wake
up five times a night is that because of
a kidney issue probably not if you're
waking up five times a night to urinate
whether you're a boy or girl
it's certainly not prostate issue and
women don't have prostate glands so it
can't be a prostate addition when women
wake up three four five times a night to
urinate and so you can go back and look
at the kidneys and say oh my gosh
um we got we got something going on here
in the kidneys and then there's kidney
stones where you get little BB size
calcium deposits you know the size of BB
floating around in there
and they get into your urinary bladder
and and so on and so that that tells you
you got something going on with
osteoporosis and arthritis in your body
and the calcium levels are very very
high and precipitates out in that urine
in the bladder and then the kidneys
tubes themselves and cause kidney stones
and urinary bladder stones okay and
um
and so again the kidneys are involved in
all this
so
what I do and this is why we came up
with the programs we have everybody
needs a 90 essential neutrons that's our
basic
thesis okay everybody needs a 90th
Century nutrients regardless of age
whether you're an embryo that the sperm
just fertilize the egg and you're just
now a two-celled human being you still
need to 90 essential nutrients okay then
as you grow uh as an embryo uh your body
requires all these nutrients to form all
the various organs and systems and
glands and tubes and arteries and veins
and and so on and the kidneys are
working
you know right away they're doing their
job okay they're doing what they're
supposed to do but they're getting a
blood supply and the blood supply brings
them the
um information in the urine and and you
can you say oh this does bad's got to go
okay and and the glomeruli filter the
urine okay and um
get the bad stuff out and that's why I
see all this stuff in your urine okay
because your glomeruli are filtering out
the bad stuff and laying the bad stuff
go out with the urine and keeping the
good stuff in the bloodstream like red
blood cells that kind of stuff okay
so with that said
um your kidneys require all the good
stuff just like your heart and your
liver and your lungs and and so forth
um your brain requires all the good
stuff and so you want to make sure
you're taking the 90 essential in your
dreams and myself because you know I had
long hours and I'm dealing with all
kinds of people and who knows what bugs
they have I take the health abandoned
heart pack which is the 90 essential
nutrients with 250 excuse me with 115
other
um uh nutrients added to it so it has
215 nutrients in it including the 90
okay and that's going to make your
kidneys happy
and then you know if you have a lot of
sugar coming through your urine you want
to make sure you're getting to add to
that these sweeties that's going to help
you with your blood sugar problems okay
and then the blood pressure issues
that's why we have the ultimate daily
classic tablets three words ultimate
daily classic tablets I I only win 142
and I I don't have blood pressure
problems I take three twice a day so I
can keep my blood pressure down in you
know into the normal
Zone
and then
um so that we're dealing with the
sweeties we're dealing with the ultimate
daily Classics that was we're dealing
with with the blood sugar issues we're
dealing with the blood pressure issues
and then the toxicity okay the toxicity
and that's why I like the book rare
husband cures go to chapter 10 11 starts
at page 272 get a hair analysis and
that's going to tell you if you're
getting all the essential nutrients you
need are you absorbing because the same
thing that's happening in your kidneys
is happening in your intestines of the
little thing like villain your
intestines
so you're getting kind of a
screening test when you take a urine
test
uh you're getting a screening test so
you take your blood pressure you're
getting a screening test so you want to
take care of your kidneys and they will
take care of you okay and so in the old
days
you know I'm going to say something here
I hope I don't offend anybody
um you know when when people really
fired up in the old days
and really doing great things and you
know beyond what the average person was
doing man they're full of piss and
vinegar okay because you know they have
the stuff okay and so
because people recognize they didn't
know all the chemistry details back
hundreds of years ago and thousands of
years ago but they did know the kidneys
were important okay and so this is
unimpeachable stuff it's been known for
a long time and again they're kind of a
barometer what goes on there you don't
have to cut your body open to look
that's what a urine sample is for that's
what a blood sample is for okay and now
we have the the magic of the of the MRI
okay magnetic resonance imaging so you
can see what's going on oh my gosh you
got some kidney stones
well why did you even look for that well
you know I was urinating too many times
every once in a while I have a few drops
of blood in there so I said well maybe
there's a stone in there sure enough
so and we have kidney stones or bladder
stones are telling you that you have
stuff going on like osteoporosis and
arthritis and your body is shedding
uh calcium or and other minerals or
maybe not getting them they may just not
be getting them and your kidney is
yelling say give me give me give me here
we need this stuff because I'm getting
wiped out here because we're you know
all the wrong
metabolism here so your kidneys are
great warnings don't forget the salt we
have the seasoned salt from Australia
New Zealand we have the Himalayan salt
for the Himalayas mountains they have I
don't know 28 minerals plus the sodium
chloride
don't let a doctor talk you into giving
up salt salt is required by every cell
in your body for cell function
your kidneys require salt for kidney
function okay
and so and and they knew
a thousand two thousand three thousand
years ago
then salt
was good and so when somebody did
something good three thousand years ago
in the days of the Old Testament they
were called the salt of the earth
why would we call people the salt of the
earth if salt was bad
okay and so I'm very excited about this
we've had the opportunity I can't thank
Becca enough
they're saying say something about the
kidneys doc okay well I you know okay I
started writing down all the things the
kidney is doing oh my gosh
um you know the average person has no
idea how much the kidneys do so there
they should be one of your
favorite organs your kidneys your liver
your lungs your heart your brain
and of course muscle is important to get
from here to there bones are essential
from getting from here to there your
bone marrow also produces your immune
system including white blood cells
regulates and antibodies so they're all
kind of connected and right in the
middle of it all are the kidneys so with
that said I'm gonna flip this over
to Rebecca
all right thank you so much for that
doctor
I'm here are you here
I'm here there you are
yeah
so yes so Dr well like there there are
so many different things that the
kidneys do
that when not functioning properly they
affect other parts of the body which
then
you know what's going on in the kidneys
as being the root cause but doctors
don't know to look for that
and the root cause is normally
nutrient deficiencies
right that's correct that's correct or
dehydration yeah just dehydration
well yeah
because dehydration
um the kidneys can't do their job if
it's not getting enough fluid to keep
all the bad stuff in solution to urinate
them out okay all the bad stuff then
deposit somewhere maybe in your liver
kind of thing which is not a good thing
maybe in your heart which is not a good
thing maybe in your brain which is not a
good thing maybe in your lungs not a
good thing so you really want optimal
hydration so that your kidneys can do
their function you need to have all 90
essential nutrients which are required
by the kidney to do their function
okay and so that's an unimpeachable
Evidence okay the kidney ranks up there
in the top four or five systems that are
required by your body to give you
maximum health and maximum longevity
so I want to repeat something that she
said
dehydration prevents the kidneys from
being able to do what they were designed
to do
that is correct
so something that gets me Dr Wallach is
when somebody's having kidney issues
and they're told to not have more than
32 ounces of fluids per day
I mean and that's even for a 200 pound
person
that's like dehydration levels
it's like telling somebody who owns a
car just put a pint of oil in your car
because your engine is heating up
a pint when it requires six quarts
that's right yeah that wouldn't work
great analogy doc
great analogy so just something to think
about folks
if you're not getting enough fluids to
the body you can't expect your body and
the organs to function the way that
they're supposed to
it's like we need fluids
for the blood to be produced is it's
it's a fluid if we don't have the fluids
coming into their body and the body is
continually making blood which is
manufactured in the bone marrow
we don't have healthy bones we don't
have healthy blood we don't have enough
fluids
does the blood get thicker your blood
clots
all right you heard it folks if you're
suffering from blood clots take a look
at your fluids and the nutrition that
you are putting into your mouth if
you're not getting the nutrition and
you're not getting the fluids how can
you expect the body to be able to do
what it was designed to do
you're expecting a lot
too much maybe
so be willing to take care of your body
you are worth it you're worth the
investment of getting proper nutrition
you are worth
drinking that extra half gallon of water
whether you have to pee or not it's a
normal function folks it's okay to go
pee throughout the day
and if you're eating it's okay to have a
bowel movement for every time that you
eat
we hear a lot Dr Wallach
we hear a lot of concerns whenever you
know people don't have a bowel movement
except for maybe once or twice
a week
and then we look at their diet
they don't like to drink water
they're only drinking sodas
they have kidney issues they have blood
pressure issues
and you wonder why
it's not rocket science
what doctors will say it's genetic
yeah they'll say it's genetic well or
take some Pepto-Bismol
hahaha
90 essential nutrients Dr Wallach
instead of just putting a Band-Aid over
One symptom that we're having hi Joe I
believe you've got it let's give the
body what it needs not just to survive
or barely survive
day to day wishing that your days were
short
no let's Thrive folks you have a purpose
to be on this Earth You were given a
body and the job to take care of the
body and we're here to help you do it
because you're not going to be hearing
the information here from many other
places
it's and it's playing it's plain and
simple
that garbage in garbage out good stuff
in good stuff out and that good stuff
out includes longer life
feeling better each and every day yes
there's going to be times where we have
accidents there's going to be a time
that hey the maker calls you home
whether you're ready or not I
think that we need to be ready and plan
for each and every day
and if he wants us to be here to 120
years Dr Wallach we need to take care of
the body that's going to get us there so
we have some questions here in the chat
and also on YouTube
and
through emails and text messages that
come through so I want to make sure that
we get to as many as absolutely possible
that was a great introduction on kidneys
it makes you think folks
just because
you go to the bathroom too much or not
enough
it's not a bladder issue
not necessarily it could be but for the
most part when the gut body has what it
needs it's going to function better and
it's going to break down less
so let's go for that
you are tuning in to daily with Doc so
welcome welcome welcome everybody my
name is Becca Dukes I am the hostess of
this program and I am honored humbly
honored to be the hostess of this
program and I want to thank all of our
coaches and Associates that are here
with us thank you for being here with us
I know many of you come to gather
information to build your knowledge base
your toolbox so that you can go out and
help others your clients your future
clients find Optimal Health as well and
I love the fact that you come in and
bring questions the questions that you
are bringing whether you're a coach
whether you're an individual whether
you're a current customer with
youngevity or a future customer with
youngevity we welcome you all
you want to make sure that you get back
with the person that shared this program
with you if there's nobody to think then
we do have a call team of certified
holistic health coaches standing by at
855-949-3377 again this is for people
who have never spoken to in to anybody
about youngevity before who have never
tried the youngevity products that Dr
Wallach is going to be mentioning in
this program that's
855-949-3377 or if you prefer email go
to dailywithdoc.com and use that contact
us and I'll make sure that we get back
in contact with you
so the first question I have here Dr
Wallach is from Lynn and Lynn has a
customer who is 71 years old
five foot two inches
40 pounds
she's on a lot of prescription drugs no
wait a minute you said 40 pounds
140 pounds you just said 40 pounds
probably sorry
I'm glad you're paying attention oh yeah
my kidneys are good
your kidneys and your ears good
glad to hear it
um but this client Dr Wallach has low
B12
and she's wondering why she does take
the Z radical and a lot of B vitamins
she's on a lot of prescriptions and
they're wanting to know why would she
have low B12 so she's not absorbing B12
if she's taking it and what would be the
best option for her she doesn't mention
what other issues that she's having
that's put it put her on several
pharmaceutical drugs
okay
um basically we need to have a hair
analysis of this gal find out what's
going on there but to to increase
the
vitamins okay you need to be taking
again
our
program that deals with the vitamins
okay I like the the
um healthy brain and heart pack the
health rated hard pack that's that's our
heavy duty hammer it has 215 nutrients
including B12
okay
215 nutrients has the 90 including B12
and that's kind of what I would go I
wouldn't just pick out one to to take
more of I would do the whole thing and
stay away from the bad foods no fried
foods no processed means no oils no
glutens no wheat nobody around those so
sugar no carbon or drinks even the diet
one's got to go also you know the diet
drinks as well as the carbonated water
because they neutralize stomach acid so
you cannot absorb nutrition
in
but you know we provided in the healthy
brain and um
heart pack plenty of E12 so that's where
I would go I would you know get a big
hammer that has everything in it so
you're not adding more individual things
that you have to to get everything you
need
so that's where I would go
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
so we're talking about you know the the
foundation and making sure that we get
the foundation and not just hand picking
or cherry picking one nutrient yeah
per month and it's a day okay
all right thank you so much and next
let's go to Seth who has his hand up so
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with Dr Wallach
hey Dr Walla can you hear me yes sir yes
sir yes okay
um so
I have got a church friend who
um I ran into him
at his job and he was hunched over he's
not doing good at all
and he's about you know mid 40s
really tall guy six three six four 250
pound guy
hadn't seen him in a while
and um
he looks horrendous and one of the
reasons he told me that he looked so bad
he's gained 52 pounds it's because he
broke his foot but at the same time it's
a separate issue
um it's a great thing that you're
talking about kidneys and the urinary
tract because
um he just had his third surgery that I
didn't know about and that's because the
doctors are saying that his urethra is
inflamed
um and so I asked him about his kidneys
and he says that and of course what the
doctors say I take that with a grain of
salt but uh the doctors say
that his kidney function looks fine but
it's really with his bladder and his
urethra like he told me and this is the
last piece of information because I know
I've got to keep keep it brief but let
me ask you let me ask you yes sir
does he complain about
urinating many times a night waking up
five ten times a night to urinate
no sir I'll ask him
um because I know you're going to say
osteoporosis of the skull neck that
could be yeah that's correct I'll
definitely ask him about that that's a
good point
um but what he told me about his uh
bladder and and how often he uses the
restroom he says that he can't use the
bathroom
all day long
um and then because it like pulls up and
his kidneys in order excuse me in his
bladder and then in the morning it just
he urinates forever and ever and ever
but throughout the day he tries to use
the bathroom but his urethra is so
um plugged up I guess that he can't let
go and he can't do that but he can do
that you have to be nerves affecting
the urinary bladder okay the the
um the spinal cord when it gets squeezed
it tells these the urinary bladder
urinate or not urinate so I suspect this
guy's got osteoporosis of the skull so
you're right on so here we go
um none of the bad foods no fried foods
no process amazing oils no glutens no
wheat and above around oats no buckwheat
uh absolutely
those are the Fatal Pyrenees no sugar no
um absolutely no carbon or drinks
including soft drinks and and also
carbonated water and then 250 pounds on
them to have two healthy grain and heart
patch for months I think twice a day I
wanted him to
um have two bottles a month of the MSM
so we take three breakfast certain lunch
at dinner time they're going to support
and promote mange repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between invertebrate bone rate
bone itself
and then I also want him to get the
um one meal a day a keto Shake
okay
um in 250 yeah I'd like to see him weigh
about 210 so he may be 30 40 pounds
overweight and so
uh won him uh also uh to uh get the a
keto Shake either the chocolate or
vanilla or both and one keto meal per
day okay one keto meal per day it's a
meal replacer it's not to be added to a
meal
and he can lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day and um but you have to it's
again
it's just the keto shake you can't add
it to a meal it's a meal replacer
and um
that's so that's that's where I would go
and so let's see if the problems are
actually going on because the spinal
cord is being squeezed
as opposed to the doctors
very commonly incorrectly thinking it's
happening Downstream in his groin okay
um it doesn't make sense uh it's
positionals that you know he lays down
at night and he doesn't get up at night
to urinate but as soon as he wakes up
he's peeing all morning okay that tells
me it's a positional thing that tells me
the odds are is this skull squeezing the
spinal cord and some spinal cord issue
um very very very common
okay
all right thank you Seth let's go right
over to Ruth Ellen who has a question
for you Dr Wallach okay
hello Dr Wallach and everybody out there
um I have a couple questions on YouTube
so I have
um
who's your proud
it says that he is a hunt um five foot
two weighs 134 pounds and no health
issues that he knows of he's 55 years
old and no medications
he also said that he got a blood test uh
he had a test for work
and it said is zero on blood sugar test
does that mean
I'm not insulin resistant
what is test show
um it said okay I'm just reading it the
way he wrote it in um he has a zero on a
blood sugar test
um make a test or he had no blood sugar
right no blood sugar so um he has no
blood sugar is that in his urine or is
that in his blood
actually I don't know so if you can um
tell me while I'm talking to Dr Wong
that would be great
um so he had he had been fasting when he
took the test
and but I can't burn fat so I don't know
why I still think I'm I'm insulin
resistant
sorry
okay and I'm looking to see if he's
telling me yeah we need to know how many
times 90 urinates we need to know what
his blood sugar levels are
um you know we need to know some more
information this is on YouTube though I
get limited information so let's just go
with 100
with 154 pounds I'll give you kind of a
basic program here but we need one it's
134 134 okay yes sir
and so now basically you need to get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils or gluten so
wheat bread I know so sugar no
carbonated drinks including carbonated
water
no buckwheat and then
um I I'd be a little heavy-handed here
um zero blood sugar that's very scary
okay if you have zero blood sugar that
means you're dead and that is urine test
Dr Wallach yes
you just found out
it was a urine test okay okay so that's
good okay so anyway we wanted to have
two healthy branded heart passion months
photos everything twice a day I wanted
to have two bottles a month of our
ultimate uh
MSM MSM so we take three breakfast lunch
at dinner time and then um I wanted him
also to have a scoop of our collagen
peptides in this morning drinking his
evening drink those two cancers per
month
and let's see here we want him to take
our rebounders for shrink okay for more
um let's see here for more hydration
more nutrition and more energy
okay if he's gonna use the cans he's got
to pop the cans the night before put
them in the refrigerator drink them the
next day you don't drink them right away
because we don't want them to have the
carbonation but we do have the sticks
there's 30 sticks in a box and each one
is a full dose of the rebound and then
we do have the canister there's 36
servings of Rebound in the canisters and
again is 100 nutrients in it
and but the cans do have carbonation so
got to be careful there pop them the
night before putting a refrigerator
drink one at breakfast I also drink a
half of one at lunch and the other half
of that second one penetrate drain
during the afternoon so I can't keep my
energy up okay but um when these people
contact us we need a little bit more
information so we can be more specific
but you know as a general program I
think we're covering the Waterfront here
okay awesome awesome thank you I have
one more question off of uh YouTube and
I have very limited information here as
well
um
I don't know GN gutic
um wants to know how
they can soften their feet
um they're five foot ten they weigh 165
pounds and they have diabetes and that
is all the information I have
and when it's soften their feet Yes but
maybe they have a lot of calluses on
their feet
their computer cracked maybe mm-hmm
okay so get rid of all the bad foods no
fried food no processed meat no oils no
glutens no buckwheat no uh sugar no
carbonated drinks including carbonated
soft drinks and also carbonated water
and then
um I'd go with the two healthy brain and
heart packs for mouthful it was
everything twice a day I'd have them
take two bottles a month of the MSM so
we take three of breakfast here at lunch
at dinner time okay to deal with the
bones and the skin and collagen and
connective tissue and all that kind of
stuff including the skin I also wanted
to have the Hair Skin and Nails go ahead
and take
um three of those twice a day Hair Skin
and Nails the title is self-explanatory
and then because of the diabetes someone
to get two bottles a month of the
sweeties I'd take three of those twice a
day I don't have diabetes but I take
three twice a day just to because I want
to get all the raw materials I'm in case
okay and um take three of the sweeties
breakfast through dinner time and if
he's on medication don't cold turkey off
the medication but as the blood sugar
begins to drop you can still reduce the
medication based on the actual numbers
okay so that's kind of where I'd go with
this guy
okay thank you very much and that is all
that we have on YouTube at this time
all right thank you so much Ruth Ellen I
appreciate you coming on and keeping an
eye out there
um helping me keep an eye on everything
that's going on so we have a question Dr
Wallach that is coming in from a
listener
um it's actually coming from one of our
coaches in regards to a listener and we
have a couple who they they share some
of the same
same issues Dr Wallach
and there are different weights
they have fungus
feet fungus they also have psoriasis
they also share or both have vaginal
itching
um they've been treated for overgrowth
wait a minute wait a minute you say they
both have vaginal Nations so this is a
lesbian couple yes sir okay
so and there's no other health concerns
there's no high blood pressure there's
no diabetes it's just they've got the
vaginal itching the fungus and the
psoriasis so what would you recommend
and they also mentioned that when they
take
um
multivitamins that it seems to increase
okay
so what they need to do is get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils or glutens and
Wheaton of our rhinos no buckwheat no
sugar no carbonated or drinks and no
carbonated water okay and then
I would have these ladies take per 100
pounds of body weight one healthy brain
and heart pack per month and if they
only weigh 110 pounds each then they
could take a half of those or anything
twice a day if they weigh 135-150 pounds
or more each then they need to take two
so they take a full dose of everything
twice a day right okay and I also want
them to have our Zara them they can go
each get a bottle of zero film take
three of those twice a day that's going
to give their ovaries what they need to
make
um
things you know like um hormones female
hormones all kind of stuff estrogen and
so on progesterone and then also I would
have them take our colloidal silver they
could take uh you know they'll go
through two bottles a month each of our
colloidal silver because I wanted to
take two droppers full when they wake up
in the morning under their tongue two
drivers full say five or ten minutes
before each meal so it's three times a
day and then also before bedtime and the
there's no alcohol in it so it won't
burn I also wanted to have the Hair Skin
and nails they have skin issues okay
have psoriasis right
yes okay so they need the Hair Skin and
Nails I only have three of those twice a
day
and they can also use in addition to
orally they can take the the
um colloidal silver on a cotton ball and
wherever they have fungus in their
fingernails or toenails or in between
their toes or fingers or something like
that
they could go ahead and and do that
there's no alcohol and it won't burn in
open wounds and so forth okay and so
that's kind of where I would start
could they put it in a spray bottle and
spray the area with the colloidal silver
would that be too much no that's fine
okay
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and next we have Marilyn who has
a question here Marilyn
go ahead and unmute yourself you're on
live with Dr Wallach hi everybody I had
a question in the chat from Michelle
and she had heard that pink Himalayan
salt is retrieved through explosive
mining techniques
so she said the bottom line is it has
explosives in it
so what's your opinion on that okay well
we see you have to appreciate
the Himalayan mountains are very very
big
okay I mean we're we're talking about
they covering a lot of area
and so every mine that produces
Himalayan salt
doesn't blow up a mountain to get
handling and salt we don't blow up
mountains to do that okay so we're we're
getting the Himalayan salt where there's
an ocean
millions of years ago when the ocean
dried up all the seaweed and everything
fell to the valleys and and so forth as
the water went away and all that to
seaweed had minerals in it and this is
where we get our minerals we don't we
don't blow up things
well thank you
and did you have another question
Marilyn or was that the only other
question from the chat
um well I have something personal
go ahead if you have a personal question
Now's the Time okay when you take
vitamins they always everyone I'll add
minerals and supplements it always says
you're going to get toxic especially
like trace minerals like copper they say
if you take too much you're gonna have
time who's saying this
um I've had clients I have other coaches
and what I'm getting at is medical
doctors saying that stuff it's like
medical doctor saying don't take salt it
causes high blood pressure yeah no but
this isn't for medical doctors this is
from you know they get the information
from medical doctors oh I see
okay and I put that into what the type
of science called crabola have you ever
heard of crapola yes okay well there you
go
well because I have taken a lot of
supplements even before youngevity
fragmented and I didn't see results but
I took way more than the FDA
recommendation even for copper and stuff
and I never have had a problem never so
and I know I was following your protocol
that says we're eating gluten were you
eating wheat bread around oats
no no I mean yes at the time yeah
that's why you weren't getting any
results because you weren't observing I
see
but now uh for two years now I've been
on your protocol and now
right I'm not even including gluten but
I have no problem with taking too much
like the body like you said it
recognizes it of vitamin and mineral so
it adjusts right if it's too much it
will excrete it right well that's what
your kidneys are for they're the traffic
cop
okay excellent because yeah because I
have never had a toxicity problem and so
yeah here analysis get hair analysis
okay
okay well thank you rare Earth's been
cures page 272. and
I'm with Maryland though that I took Pro
I took lots of other vitamins and never
felt a difference and when I started
taking the youngevity vitamins I didn't
know that I had to be gluten free
and I felt a difference even eating the
gluten now that I am gluten free the
difference is even better
so I mean there is a big difference
between taking the supplementation and
getting absorption and then
changing the diet so that you could get
optimal absorption because things just
get better folks yeah now let me
interrupt here what we do for people
that haven't struggled with absorption
they can take our liquid plant minerals
which has 75 minerals in it okay and rub
it on the belly rub it on the sternum in
the middle of the chest rubbing between
the shoulder blades in the back spray
spray it on and rub it in okay and it's
almost like intravenous like in in
seconds it's absorbed and we have
literally hundreds and hundreds of
testimonies of people everything from
Pastor Mike Freeman who was in a coma
for six weeks and and to so many kids so
many babies with all these problems and
we just rub these
um minerals on the babies and turn them
around and that's why we went and we
actually sued okay the FDA in federal
court to make sure that we could get all
these nutrients into the baby formula so
it wouldn't have to keep rubbing
minerals on the kids backs and stuff
like that
yeah well I'm thankful Dr Wallach that
there there's multiple ways to go about
doing things and folks
the plant Drive minerals are very
affordable very affordable there's
absolutely no reason why somebody would
not be able to add that into their daily
activities whether it's spring I even
spray it on my face and my neck and my
belly and everything after a shower and
just air dry
I'll spray it into my hair
um it's just amazing Dr well like what
the plant Drive minerals do and ladies
if you like that
well okay if you like that look that's
kind of like the sea salt this I think
it's like the beach
Beach hair look
um the plan dry minerals they're like
multi-purpose
and because I use those in my spray uh
for for my hair and of course then it's
absorbing into my scalp which is then
getting into the bloodstream and just
does an amazing job
and I I think it's doing an amazing job
Dr Wally because as I Look to do some
pictures I was looking hard because
I'm a photographer
so I'm always on the back side of the
camera
so it was hard to find pictures of me
with me on the other side of the camera
but when I did and I looked at it I put
some up on Facebook I've had so many
people say I look younger now than I did
even seven years ago
um and I see it
I see it I I like what I'm seeing now
compared to what
yeah you look like you're struggling
with before
I'm sorry you look like you're 25 years
old
thank you I think I'll keep you okay
I might ask for a raise but that works
for me thank you Dr Wallach let's go to
Michelle who has her hand up and
Michelle go ahead and unmute yourself
hi I was on a call Prime about two three
weeks ago I'm
female of course five four and at that
time I weighed 151 now I weigh 153.
um and I
um my I'm new I'm not even through one
month of products yet but
um
I am
probably should tell you my problem
first is like I make enough T4 it's not
converting to T3
and I also have insomnia complex PTSD
and TBI and Dr Wallach suggested I take
eat six eggs a day I don't like eggs and
that's just a challenge so
um then also I'm on they started me on
Trazodone for sleep because I have
insomnia like sometimes not sleep at all
at night
um
I'm
so that's the update
um and my questions with updates is why
I'm feeling like I can't eliminate
completely or sometimes even
um
I'm constipated for like a couple of
days and I know that I'm drinking enough
water like have my weight in ounces and
I was like well maybe I need more fiber
so I was taking different kinds of like
xylem husk or this other one that I
bought that was expensive and
um I'm concerned that I have a gut issue
because let's stop there okay because we
only have moments okay so let's stop
there so the gut issue you need to get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed Meats no oils no glutens no
Wheaton oh so buckwheat no sugar no
carbonated drinks even though diet
drinks need to go and also carbonated
water needs to go okay then I want you
to take um you said 155 pounds correct
yeah okay I want you 153 155. I want you
to take two healthy brain and heart
pasture month to pull those everything
twice a day I want you to get two
bottles a month of the msms you take
three brackets three unless you're
dinner time and then I also want you to
have our
let's see here I want you to take our
Ocean's gold go ahead and take three of
those I actually start out with three
three times a day get three there's
small little bottles okay and then once
we get things under control you can cut
it back down to three twice a day for
maintenance all right and then I want
you to have a rebound or sports drink
and that's going to help you with the
bowel movement as well as
um the energy and so forth to make sure
um that if you're going to use the cans
make sure you're popping them the night
before put them in the refrigerator so
you can use them the next day when
they're flat right but we also have the
sticks each one is a serving of rebound
okay it's called rebound the stick
there's 30 of these in a box we have the
canisters there's 36 servings in the
canisters a little scoop in there two of
the little Scoops in a bottle of water
you know like this that gives you the
right dosage of the rebound okay and so
it's one of those things where I'd kind
of go that direction not just water but
water with stuff in it and then don't
forget the seasoned salt or the
Himalayan salt one or the other you need
those okay that's including the
um Ocean's gold okay because the ocean's
gold is primarily seaweed that we've
looked at and
processed and dried seaweed okay which
helps you I think it's like nine
different seaweeds in there to make your
thyroid heavy okay in the and that's
called seasoned salt
yeah it's called seasoned salt that's in
addition to the ocean's gold
uh
am I supposed to
everything except for the oceans gold
all at once they're like like three
times a day
well when I say take it three times a
day you take it three times a day when I
say take it twice a day you take it
twice a day I just thought you meant the
oceans gold three times a day okay thank
you oceans go because you have thyroid
issues
okay so I want you to take it three
times a day to begin with and then when
your thyroid issues go away and drop it
down to three twice a day for
maintenance
Roger that okay
okay very good yeah you're gonna have a
great story okay and so I think I
covered all your your questions
um
Dr Wally did you add in the I-26 for
digestion oh thank you and because she
didn't like eggs you know not only for
digestion but also for functioning of
the brain and spinal cord and so forth
thank you I-26 yeah we have in three
forms it comes in powder comes in
capsules comes in chewable a little disc
a little kids like them they taste like
um vanilla ice cream they're soft
chewables they're not crunchy tools but
do you want to I started out with three
servings a day you have the I-26
and that's going to give you what's good
for your for your brain your spinal cord
your nerves
um your immune system
your skin
your intestines everything's going to
work better with the I-26
yeah there is a video that I'm going to
find and get on daily with with Doc
posted there that goes through I-26 and
all the benefits of it including how it
helps with the bacteria and pathogens
within the digestive system so I'm
looking forward to getting approval to
be able to use that Michelle thank you
so much for coming on and asking your
question you're going to help a lot of
people by by stepping up and and asking
because I know there's a lot of people
that are struggling with thyroid issues
well Dr Wallach we are at the time limit
that we have with you today thank you so
much again for being on with us I just
went in with one or two more sentences
that I made please do yeah my my
favorite tissue in the body is the
thyroid gland because that was my first
scientific paper I published was one of
those 500 sheep died in one night and I
found to be
it was a police and when the temperature
for six months and they're beautiful
but when I did the other
obviously so I knew it was a thyroid
issue so why were they them if that
average dude that's okay in Central
Missouri down to 16 and one and they all
died at hypothermia because all of their
thyroids are dead so yeah I would say
that the thyroid is pretty important Dr
Wallach and cutting out those foods that
have especially the processed ones that
have added nitrates and nitrites
for preserving it
would be a really good idea
yes well thank you again Dr Wallach
we'll talk to you later
adios adios amigo
all right
yes sayonara
uh right if I could get my co-hosts up
with me that would be absolutely
fantastic as I cannot do this program
without them and folks if you're looking
for a place
to
be part of a community to help people
grow help people achieve and find a
better life whether it's physical mental
emotional
Financial then consider joining us here
at youngevity get with the person that
invited you to this program they
probably have their own community that
they are welcoming you with open arms I
know here at Daily with Doc and critical
Health news we have an amazing family
that
we do we work together it's unlike any
other direct sales or network marketing
company I've ever been part of where we
are truly in it together yes you have a
business yes it is your own business and
you can work it the way you want to but
folks you're not there alone we have
resources we have support we have
camaraderie and we have a family that
builds our youngevity businesses and if
that's something that you want to be
part of then we encourage you to step
and say Hey I want some more information
you can go to daily withdoc.com use that
contact us that's for the people that
have never spoken with anybody before
that not working with any of the
youngevity associates
and have not tried the youngevity
products if you have get back with the
person that you've been buying your
products from find out who that is get
plugged in Bobby you are amazing because
you show up you're not part of our team
but you are part of our team because we
are one team one or one dream one team I
love that o-t-o-g
um because we are a community and we
work together so get plugged in become
part of a community if
we're just we're here welcoming you
because we are a big family
thank you to my co-hosts we have Phyllis
Anderson who's been with youngevity
since part of the beginning
thank you Verna
um we have Marilyn pazera who's been
with us a few years and just really digs
into the research and taking the
youngevity products as a solution for
her health issues her family's health
issues we have sherry Browning who I
came with came to us with another
certification certification of another
coaching program
but didn't go deep into the nutrition
like we do here in youngevity and with
the certified holistic health coach
program that we have through the
Institute of holistic health you can
find more information about that you can
go to coachwith Becca coach with Ruth
Ellen and gotta find out what Sherry's
link is and what Phyllis and Maryland's
links are so that you can get plugged in
with somebody that you feel connected to
you see us here on YouTube or on
Facebook or in rumble or here live
and we just get drawn to people we feel
their energy
take if you're not working with somebody
within youngevity and your energy is
drawn towards somebody and you want to
be part of
our community
then reach out to us let us know you can
go to daily withdoc.com use that contact
us send me a message and I'll make sure
that we get the information that you are
looking for
because folks information is power and
we Empower you today and every day until
next time
thanks for tuning in to daily with Doc
what did I forget
thank you out there on YouTube land
sport is nutritionist yes we are so
happy thank you for helping people give
us the information that we need so thank
you thank you
yes
thank you AJ
appreciate you and all you do out there
so we have a big team and this is not
even a portion of the team we have the
other people that are spiritual healers
we have doctors we have
naturopathic doctors we have uh oncology
surgeons we have chiropractors we have
functional medicine practitioners our
family is just expanding and not just in
the United States but in Canada Mexico
the United Kingdom we have uh folks in
Kenya South America Nigeria South Sudan
Pakistan uh Saudi Arabia Dubai
Russia and Czechoslovakia I mean these
are just the ones that I can remember at
this very moment Sweden
Ireland it's amazing we are an
international company and even if
youngevity doesn't ship to you directly
we have ways to get product to you so
that you also can experience the benefit
of the youngevity difference
because there is a huge difference than
what you would buy anywhere else
so I'm gonna say bye one more time
and we'll see you tomorrow bye for now
recording stuff
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you